ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATION CONVEYANCE --
WE HAVE SEVEN MEMBERS PRESENT
AND A QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO HERE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALL YOU.
THERE ARE.
MANY NEXT OVER. THIRTY
PRESENTING HIRING.
SOMEHOW YOU KNOW HOW THE BRAIN
DOESN'T WANT.
TO IT REALLY FELT RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
MEGABYTES DOT
.
I THINK MR LOW YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THESE ARE
TECHNICAL WOMEN VERSUS THEIR
SPEC WE ASK PRIVATE AND THEY
KEEP YOUR COMPETITION.
JENNIFERTANNA HELL WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THAT TAXICAB PARA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WORKED
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAFT THIS
CLEAN UP BILL AND WE REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE BILL FOR
QUITE SAN FRANCISCO FROM.
THE REGULATIONS I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS TO ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK FOR THE REGULATION OF
THE TAXICAB INDUSTRY.
WHY IT MAKES SENSE TO EXEMPT FOR
THE MOST POPULOUS CITIES IN THE
STATE --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
A HUMAN ARE PROBABLY FAMILIAR
WITH THE MEDALLION SYSTEM THAT
IS UNIQUE TO SAN FRANCISCO IN
MANY OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT IS
NOT THE SAME CASE THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE SO.
OF THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO THAT
OF THE PROPERTY.
OF THE CITY COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO BUT DID JENNIFER TEN
HOW CAN ALSO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL.
SO THE MEDALLION SYSTEM MEN'S
AND SAN FRANCISCO IS NOT
CONSIDERED AN ACTUAL BUT WHEN
YOU.
PURCHASE THE MEDALLION IT'S
CONSIDERED A PROPERTY RIGHT.
AND SO ANY CHANGES TO THE MOUNT
MEDALLION SYSTEM --
INSIDE AND SAN FRANCISCO WOULD
UPSET THAT PROCESS AND IN THE
CITY BACKS THE LOANS THAT THE
SPECIFIC CREDIT UNIONS.
PROVIDE FOR THE MEDALLION AND SO.
ANY CHANGE TO THAT SYSTEM WOULD
IMPACT THE CITY AND THE CITY
BUDGETS AND REVENUES AND SO WE
DIDN'T WANT TO OPEN THAT CAN OF
WORMS AND SAN FRANCISCO HAD
REQUESTED TO BE A TO OPT OUT.
WE WANT TO SEE RESPECT REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES PART OF CRAFTING THE
BILL WAS THAT AND AND ONE REASON
THAT WE DID COUNTY BY COUNTY WAS
TO RESPECT SOME OF THOSE
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES --
AND THE WAY WE DRAFTED THE
BILL'S PRETTY BROAD AND AS FAR
AS WHAT COUNTIES CAN DO --
LOCALLY AND CITIES A INDIVIDUAL
CITIES SEE I AM WITH THEIR TAXI
BUSINESSES BUT WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
SAN FRANCISCO REMAINED EXEMPT
SINCE THEY DID NOT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE SO IS THE PLAN OVER
TIME -- TO
MELD THESE INTO ONE OVERALL
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OR IS THE PLAN
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE --
ONE SET A STANDARD FOR THE STATE
AND ANOTHER FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN THERE WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
WE DON'T HAVE A AN ONGOING PLAN
BESIDES THIS AT THIS VERY WELL
THANKS I JUST JUMPED OUT AT ME
WHEN I READ THE BILL THE TIE
THANKS FOR YEAH THE THE ANSWER.
ANY M. CLOSING STATEMENTS FROM
THE AUTHOR.
WELL FIRST A SECOND MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS WITH A RECOMMENDATION
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED AND SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
COME LIKE A DOVE AYE LOW AYE AYE
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUICKSILVER [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I THEIR EMOTIONS.
WHAT KIND OF ZERO MEASURES OUT?
WE'RE TO KEEP THE RULE LOOPING --
FOR THE NEXT THREE MINUTES
.
ADEQUATE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB NINE THREE NINE SLOW.
MOTION IS WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS